rue de la cité sans doute la seule rue
en france traversant une cité agricole
une cité modèle unique médaillée d'or à
l'exposition universelle de 18 182
construite fin 19ème siècle avec des
matériaux locaux
la cité est constituée d'habitation est
une ferme modèle
elle fait partie d'un projet avant
gardiste qui s'appuie sur les théories
hygiéniste emmanuel mène une étude de ce
patrimoine
pourquoi ils finissent mme parce que en
fait si on regarde bien les bâtiments
sont construits autour d'une cour ils
sont séparés c'est justement pour éviter
les épidémies contagion est aussi son
penser de façon à ce qu'on travaille
avec rentabilité à la tête de ce projet
un enfant du pays
françois philibert de cet héritier du
domaine agricole ce notaire parisien
conçoit ce projet dans l'effervescence
des idées nouvelles de la capitale c'est
un homme qui va évoluer justement dans
ce milieu parisien des urbanistes parce
que c'est l'époque d'haussmann donc avec
les grands projets en fait il va prendre
une idée qui s'est développée dans le
monde industriel c'est-à-dire les cités
ouvrières du nord notamment celles qu'on
a en tête c'est les mines du nord qui
mine de charbon et il va mettre en fait
le principe de ces habitations en place
ici à champigny mais dans un contexte
agricole
donc ça c'est assez innovant pour
françois philibert desseigne l'exode des
ouvriers agricoles vers la ville et ses
centres industriels est due notamment à
la qualité des logements et des services
alentours alors en 1870 il lance la
construction de sa cité en espérant
comme il le devise est que les
populations face souche
donc ça c'est la maison du régisseur qui
devient après le sanatorium tout à fait
une maison à bourgeoise bruno architecte
et directeur du conseil d'architecturé
d'urbanisme et de l'environnement du
loir-et-cher participent à l'étude
patrimoniale sa conception ses 2
de dresser des modèles d'habitat cinq
modèles récurrent qui vont lui permettre
de dessiner ensuite 38 maisons qui sont
des petites unités et des unités doubles
des unités un peu plus cossus en
fonction de la position occupée par
l'habitant et tout ça c'est pas gratuit
parce que ces deux scènes qui paye on a
des prix moyen autour de 5000 francs et
ensuite celle où et françois philibert
de singles loués à bas prix il a investi
plus de 200 mille francs stratégiquement
dans sa cité agricole alors philanthrope
ou investisseur avisé il ya un facteur
qui est conjoncturelle qui ce qui se
passe au delà dans cette deuxième moitié
du 19e siècle au niveau européen c'est à
dire des grands patrons de capitalisme
voilà industriels qui s'empare à la fois
l'outil de production et en même temps
de la question des logements dédiés aux
ouvriers 1 on allie schneider au creusot
n'a le familistère de godin on a par
exemple les logements de la cité mama
tour un de l'imprimerie mame donc on
voit bien qu'il ya des patrons qui
viendra ce mouvement là
françois philibert 2,5 construit pendant
30 ans outre les maisons et la ferme il
fait bâtir une maison de retraite un
asile une poste une boulangerie installa
demeure un médecin vétérinaire
pourtant tout cela ne suffira pas il a
pensé cette cité comme quelque chose
qu'on ne veut pas quitter parce qu'on
nous trouve tout ce qu'il faut c'est
vraiment un projet d'aidé mis démesurée
par rapport au viage mais il avait ce
but justement d'amener plus de gens et
malgré toute cette bonne volonté
l'exode rural va quand même se faire et
pourquoi parce que fini vers desseigne
malgré ce projet ambitieux n'arrivera
jamais à relier le village à des des
voies de communication importante qu'on
suit voilà un siècle et demi ce
patrimoine se révèle extrêmement moderne
à tel point que la cité toujours habité
n'a pas subi de modifications profondes
c'est incroyablement moderne mais c'est
surtout parce que ça répond à des
problématiques actuelles la vie
collective
les lotissements le fait surtout d'une
économie locale
ça c'est intéressant ça revient à
ajouter à la mode mais c'est vrai que le
fait de travailler sur l'agriculture
locale biologique avec un travail à
proximité c'est revivre localement c'est
des problématiques actuellement qui
parle aux collectivités qui veulent se
développer et la champigny en beauce
on a cet exemple qui s'est fait au 19e
siècle
pourrait-on imaginer demain des sites et
rural dont la proximité entre habitants
néo ruraux et agriculteurs entraînerait
un intérêt local commun suffisamment
fort pour éviter la désertification
pourrait-on faire souche comme françois
philibert de singles imaginaire télé
sans doute l'enjeu pour les 45% d'euros
en france